nicolas sarkozy bonsoir et maintenant
avec nous alors on s'est d'abord invités
on le voit il ne vous a pas échappé que
votre formule sur le nettoyage a pu
choquer et des critiques
rien n'était joué un peu partout quand
son cerveau à l'assemblée nationale et
jean mobilité mais non non juste un mot
si on permettait sa choquer ceux qui
n'ont jamais mis les pieds dans cette
cité ça n'a pas choqué les habitants
j'ai passé deux heures et demie dans
cette cité et qu'est ce qu'ils m'ont dit
les habitants qu'ils n'en peuvent plus
et qu'ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
l'état tolère ce que nous nous tolérions
nulle part ailleurs
alors ce qui pousse des cris d'orfraie
et qui sont choqués par le verbe
nettoyer je le confirme
mon devoir c'est de nettoyer la cité des
4000 des trafics et les trafiquants
c'est dommage au terme mais bien sûr et
vous savez ce qui me choque moi c'est
que des individus soient capables de
tirer sur un petit garçon de 11 ans mais
je n'ai pas un prieur de secret mais
quand on voit le curriculum vitae des
gens que nous avons déférés à la justice
j'avais promis qu'on arrêterait les
coupables nous en avons trois sur quatre
et je n'arrêterai que quand on aura le
quatrième
j'avais promis qu'on irait nettoyer la
cité tous les jours nous en voyons la
police pour obtenir des résultats parce
que les plus pauvres et les plus démunis
nos compatriotes
ils ont besoin de sécurité il en retient
on aurait la face à pont sur lequel
effectivement il ya pu y avoir des
critiques fait j'allais dire
l'organisation des choses le fait
d'annoncer à l'avance une descente de
police a eu lieu durant il est ce que
parra est ce que c'est un gage
d'efficacité
vous voyez le décalage phénoménal dans
ce que disent certains responsables
politiques et ce que vivent les français
certains responsables politiques
viennent au calme et bien au chaud qui
ne connaissent pas les problèmes de
sécurité sont choqués par une expression
que tout le monde emploie et tout le
monde comprend
moi je suis choqué par la mort d'un
enfant de 11 ans et je n'accepte pas les
armes dans la cité ils ont retrouvé
et tous les jours les policiers qui tous
les jours nous retrouvons des choses
mais ce n'est qu'un début et je
retournerai la semaine prochaine pour
rencontrer les jeunes et pour essayer de
mettre les bases d'une politique de
sécurité locaux et bien savoir pourquoi
vous ne l'avez pas fait dernière fois je
n'ai pas fait pour une raison simple
c'est que je n'ai pas l'intention de
dialoguer pour rétablir l'ordre
je veux qu'on rétablisse l'ordre et on
revient vite seulement un dialogue pas
d'un inverse
j'ai passé deux heures et demi là bas
j'y retournerai et la cité des 4000 les
habitants doivent le savoir ils auront
droit à la même sécurité que les autres
c'est mon devoir je le ferai oui c'est
simple j'ai sécurité et après la
prévention mais ce sera quoi la
prévention parce qu'on dit moore ou les
associations justement prévention elles
ont moins de moyens qu'avant et steria
ya une contradiction entre action vous
avez la meilleure des préventions c'est
que les voyous qui trafiquent sache et
comprenne qu enfin maintenant ils vont
risquer quelque chose pourquoi on
n'arrive pas à la personne
mais la peur de la répression la peur de
la punition comment voulez vous les
jeunes se lèvent tôt le matin quand ils
voient d'autres jeunes de la cité 10 les
trafics et de la drogue et gagner
beaucoup plus que quelqu'un qui s'est
fait tôt le matin moi je respecte la
france qui travaille et je n'ai pas
l'intention de me laisser impressionner
par les professionnels de la pensée
unique qui depuis trente ans des cribles
et phénomène de la violence respect bras
croisés et abandonne nos compatriotes
les plus exposés à des situations
intolérables quand karl on dit qu'il ya
une paix mise à sion des esprits c'est
une formule que vous trouvez ça déplace
chaque fois que l'on dit quelque chose
de bon sens on se rapproche de monsieur
le pen
j'ai toujours combattu jean marie le pen
c'est moi qui abolit la double peine
c'est moi qui ai voulu que les musulmans
de france est une instance c'est moi qui
me bats pour la discrimination positive
et ceux qui ont profité de jean marie le
pen pendant les deux septennats de
françois mitterrand viennent me donner
des leçons aujourd'hui
alors quand je veux lutter contre la
voyoucratie contre les délinquants alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire donner des
leçons à tout le monde
oui j'ai vu que le récidiviste c'était
bon à la une d'un journal mon dieu quand
y'a un gosse de 11 ans comme a demandé
la famille de ce gosse qu'est ce qu'ils
m'ont dit colette monsieur sarkozy
arrêter les coupables
oui mon digne deuxième chose on en a
assez que dans notre pays les coupables
soient tard
et qu'ils ne soient pas pu mais là vous
avez une obligation de résultat en
l'occurrence vous êtes engagé mais
françoise laborde j'ai une obligation de
résultat
là et ailleurs pourquoi ai-je été nommé
ministre de l'intérieur pour commenter
les phénomènes pour les combattre je les
combats très est par ailleurs une
section du 29 mai je veux le dire très
simplement c'est que les français ne
supportent plus d'avoir une classe
politique comme poids des mots que
personne ne comprend il ya un trop grand
décalage entre ce que vivent les
français et ce que nous disons alors
vous avez aussi